- In the last chapter of my
forthcoming happiness book,
I have a quote by Viktor Frankl,
where he basically
says, you know,
"Don't pursue directly success.
It is something that
comes as a consequence."
And I use that because I argue
that I completely analogize
that to happiness,
and hence, I agree with Jordan.
Happiness should be
something that results
from you having adopted
the right mindsets,
the right decisions,
and so I think you mentioned
purpose and meaning.
So in one of the chapters
where I talk about
the two decisions
that are most likely to impart
either great amount of misery
or great amount of
happiness to you,
I say that the choice of
spouse that you choose
and the choice of
profession that you choose
are the ones that
are going to do that,
either make you more
miserable or happier.
(intriguing music)
- I am Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is an evolutionary
behavioral scientist,
an author of the brand new book,
"The Saad Truth
About Happiness,"
and possibly, just possibly.
the most time returning
"Rubin Report" guest,
my old friend, Gad Saad.
Welcome back to
"The Rubin Report."
- Oh, Dave, I'm so
happy to be back,
although I'm a bit dismayed
that it's not sure whether
I'm the most frequent guest.
Please check and get back
to me with those stats.
- Gad, my team, I have a
very cracked team here.
They're working overtime
to try to figure this out.
Right now, we know
that it is either you,
Jordan Peterson,
or Douglas Murray.
There's a little
murkiness around Jordan
because I've done so many
other things with him
that we sometimes count as
shows, sometimes we don't,
but I will say,
without question,
you were the first ever
guest on "The Rubin Report"
the first time I ever
did a full one-on-one
in studio sit down with
another human being
back in September of 2015.
It was a test show, but I
count it as the first show.
It was with Gad Saad.
- Eight years ago,
I can't believe it.
My goodness.
- Man, we were kids.
Remember that?
- We were kids,
and I was fatter.
- Yeah (laughs), I said to
you right before we connected
that you're half the
man you used to be.
But I guess that's a little,
why don't we start with that?
Because mostly people
tune into you on this show
to talk about your tan and
what you've been doing lately
to get that beautiful
Lebanese bronze,
but also you've lost
a bunch of weight.
You're always a happy guy.
That's what the book is about.
And by the way, I should note,
I have the uncorrected
proof here,
so I don't know if you added
any additional happiness
quotes or anything.
- Well, this is the final one,
so it's a bit more
glossy looking, yeah.
- But talk to me about how
the tan and the weight loss
are connected to
this whole thing,
and then we'll get
onto everything else.
- That's a wonderful way
to start the conversation.
So the tan comes from
my having just returned
from Portugal with my family,
and so there's all kinds of
happiness to unpack there.
Number one, having
a great spouse
with whom you can
spend your life with.
I actually discuss this
in quite a bit of
detail in the book.
And you've met her, you
know, on numerous occasions.
Having great children.
I know that you recently
became a double twice father,
so you must now finally
understand what it means
to have this unconditional,
obsessive love
for those carrying your genes
into the next generation.
And regarding the weight,
I actually discuss
that in the book
when I'm discussing
the importance
of persistence, resilience.
There's nothing magical about
how I lost about 86 pounds.
I think, from my heaviest
weight to my lightest,
I dropped 86 pounds,
and I did it by repeatedly
making the right decision
on a daily basis, right?
So it's little steps.
What is the secret?
Well, number one, I walk between
15 to 20,000 steps a day.
Now, the walking could
be on a stationary bike,
it could be on an elliptical,
it could be literally
walking outside.
But I have my phone with me
so that it's tracking every
single step that I take all day.
No matter how I feel. I have
to reach 15 to 20,000 steps.
But of course, as you,
and probably most of
your listeners know,
much of your weight loss
or weight maintenance
comes from what goes into
this gluttonous hole.
(Dave laughs)
It's about 90% of
your weight loss
is going to come
from what you eat,
and so what I try
to do basically
is hover around 15 to
1,700 calories a day.
The way that I know that
is because my lovely spouse
in a very Gestapo,
Nazi-like way,
keeps track of every single
thing that goes into my mouth.
And so at the end of the day,
she'll tell me, you know,
"You're at 1,638 calories,
don't have any more snacks."
And so by having to,
you know, be accountable
to number one, my steps,
number two to my daily calories,
bit by bit, I woke up
one day, 18 months later,
as you said, half
the man that I was.
And so there's no secret,
it's just hard work
and persistence.
- So obviously we'll
dive into a bunch
of the bullet points of
the book and all that,
but I have to say, since we've
been doing this since 2018,
a lot has changed in this world,
politically, culturally,
everything else.
You are still in Canada, I know.
I've been trying to get you
to these great United States,
preferably to the free state
of Florida for quite some time.
It hasn't happened just yet.
But I thought maybe we
could talk a little bit
about just how much
sort of culturally and
socially has changed,
and that in many ways,
these were the exact things
that we were talking about back
in 2015 and the years since.
Whether you look now
at the gender stuff
or the neoracism stuff,
all the woke stuff that
everyone talks about,
a lot of us, I
would say, me, you,
Jordan, Douglas, who
I mentioned before,
we were sort of all warning
about a lot of these things.
I can't tell how happy
should it make me
that we were right
about this stuff.
- Well, of course, it's-
- Mr. Happiness.
- That's right.
It's natural to
have a bit of an ego
in that you don't
want to be gleeful,
but you are the person,
and when I say you,
meaning all the people
that you just mentioned,
we are sitting in
the back of the room
with our hands folded saying,
"Hey, I told you so."
Not that you wish to
be gleeful about that,
but, you know, it is
frankly frustrating
because had many people, you
know, heeded our warnings,
maybe we wouldn't have gone down
the abyss of infinite lunacy
to the extent that we have.
But look, life is
auto-corrective.
Science is auto-corrective.
Bad ideas come and go.
And so, taking the point
that we mentioned earlier
about persistence
in weight loss,
we remain persistent,
we remain committed to
spreading good ideas,
and hopefully there'll
be an auto-correction
and these ridiculous ideas
will be in the dust
bin of history.
- I often ask you privately,
but I'll ask you publicly also.
What does keep you in
Canada at this point?
I ask this to basically
all my Canadian guests,
because obviously Canada
has a lot of problems
and you've had
frozen bank accounts,
not you personally,
as far as I know,
but I mean, there's been
frozen bank accounts.
The onslaught
against free speech
against the ability for
people to go to church.
Trudeau's government,
for some reason,
still continues to this day.
I mean, what really
keeps a guy like you
that caress so deeply
about these issues,
you're now living in a
place that in many ways
is, as far as a western country,
completely at odds with what
I know your beliefs are?
- Yeah, no, thank you
for that question.
It's even worse in Quebec than
the rest of Canada, right?
You can be in Alberta
and it's slightly,
or a lot, you know, less
socialist than Quebec.
So I'm truly in the
worst possible place.
What keeps me there, I
mean, there are two things.
Number one, many of
the family members
of both my wife and
I are in Montreal.
And since we have
young children,
that's always something
that's going to make
it more difficult
to extricate yourself from,
you know, the extended family.
But frankly, probably,
not probably,
definitely the number one reason
is that I'm a tenured
professor, right?
And so in academia, you know,
it's very, very difficult
to get a job as a professor.
You could be the most
accomplished professor.
For you to move from
one place to another
requires that, you know,
a million things fall
into place, right?
Now, when you're tenured,
that's the ultimate, you
know, protection, right?
I mean, the only thing that
has allowed me to survive,
you know, the fact that I
take the positions that I do,
is precisely the
protection of tenure.
And so to now walk
away from that
without having the security
of a tenured
professorship elsewhere
is very, very
difficult to do, right?
So, you know, I've
always talked about
what would be the
amount of money
that would permit me to have
an exit strategy out of Quebec.
And again, I think that if we
didn't have young children,
then that amount of money
would be much lesser
in order to exit.
So because of having
young children,
because we have a lot
of family in Montreal,
and because I'm a
tenured professor,
that's what's kept me here.
But believe me,
even later today,
it might interest you to know,
without giving too many details,
I am speaking to a college
or university in Florida
precisely to see
if there's a way
for me to be closer to you.
So that's (indistinct).
- Oh, well, I'm very,
very happy to hear that.
Do you think Canada has
hit peak lunacy yet,
or do you sense that it's
still gonna get worse?
Because I'm seeing some
level of pushback now,
not just from you, but
even some of the truckers,
and I had Tamara Lich on
who is one of the
lead trucker people.
Like, there is a new pushback
against some of the
craziness, I think.
- So I do see that
the promulgators
of the parasitic ideas
are still hanging in,
and if anything, they're
only getting worse.
I think where the improvement
that you are mentioning
is coming from is the
response to the lunacy.
And so you are right that
a greater number of voices
in all sorts of settings are
starting to find their spines,
find their testicular fortitude.
So that, you know,
makes you feel good,
but it moves so slowly, right?
It has taken, you know,
many of the people that
you've been talking about,
you know, a decade, two decades.
I mean, especially since I'm
in the academic ecosystem,
I've been warning about
these parasitic ideas
for several decades,
let alone 2014 and '15.
Remember that my area
of scientific inquiry
is applying evolutionary biology
and evolutionary psychology
in understanding human behavior,
and so a lot of these
parasitic ideas,
the rejection of biology, the
rejection of sex differences
existed within my
scientific pursuits
before they had entered
the culture wars.
And so, yes, there
is improvement,
but there's a lot
more work to be done.
- Yeah, absolutely.
All right, now to the book,
because happiness
is a big topic,
and I was thinking as I was
flipping through it before,
there's something interesting
about writing a book
about happiness,
'cause it puts a lot of
pressure on the author,
sort of the way I
always felt that Jordan
was under a lot of pressure by
writing "12 Rules for Life."
Because man, if he broke
one of those rules,
then why would you
wanna buy this book?
And to Jordan's credit,
people always ask me,
I never saw him break a rule.
I really, in all the
years I've known him,
I've never seen him do it.
But at a happiness
level, to say,
"I'm going to be the guy
that's gonna tell
people how to be happy,"
it's a lot of pressure.
Now, I know you very well
and you're happy and smiley
and you love your wife and
your kids and all that stuff,
but how much work in a life
that's been fairly complex
and had its share of
tragedy, actually,
was it to get to that
place and then to say,
"Oh, I can be a expert on this"?
- Well, thank you.
That's a fantastic question.
So maybe I'll
start by explaining
how I came to write
a book on happiness.
If you would've asked
me five years ago
was that within my radar,
I would've said no.
What led me to write,
and I actually discussed this
in the first
chapter of the book,
is that I noticed that
in my social engagements,
some of the most
powerful responses
that I would receive from people
is when I offered some
prescriptive advice, right?
Typically, I operate as
a behavioral scientist.
I operate in descriptive world.
I just describe why do
people do what they do
without saying, "This
is what you should do."
That was very much
more the purview of,
as you mentioned,
Jordan Peterson.
And also, especially because
he's a clinical psychologist,
so he's helping people.
"Don't do this pattern,
follow this pattern," right?
But then when I
noticed how much people
would respond
favorably to, you know,
some, you know,
100 character thing
that I put up on Twitter,
and then they're saying,
"My God, that's
changed my life."
And I would say, "Really?
That struck me as a rather
banal, obvious point to make."
And then so people would
write to me and say,
"Even though you're dealing
with such serious issues,
you always seem to be playful
and there's always a
twinkle in your eye
and you're always happy.
What's the secret, professor?"
And so I said, "You know
what? Why don't I take a..."
Because "Parasitic
Mind," the previous book,
was about negative mindsets,
parasitic ideas that
infect your brain.
I thought, "Well, why don't
I now complete the story
and talk about, you
know, winning mindsets,
optimal choices
that you can make."
But to your point, though,
I had the epistemic
humility, hopefully,
in writing this book,
not to guarantee you,
"Oh, if you implement these,
I guarantee you'll be happy."
All I can say is that
statistically speaking,
if you were to implement
these or adopt these mindsets,
it increases the probability
of you being happy.
So I can't-
- Let me ask you.
- Yeah.
- Well, as a man of
science, as you know,
I have two young boys here,
and they're only
two months apart.
But Justin, who's my oldest,
this kid came out
into this world
with a smile on his face
and a zest for life,
and, "I'm gonna get everything."
And Luke came out much more,
"I'm gonna look you up and down,
I'm gonna figure out what's
going on here, think about it."
And to me so much of that,
now spending so much
time with them as I do,
seems hardwired, the either,
I don't wanna say
desire for happiness,
but the predetermination
or something
that would lead someone to
be just smiling all the time
versus someone that runs
a little bit cooler.
How do you factor
that into, you know,
what makes someone happy?
- Again, fantastic question.
About 50% of differences
across people
in terms of their
happiness stems from genes.
So at first glance,
you might say,
"Oh, so it's hardwired
in my genes?"
No, because that means
there's 50% up for grabs.
So Justin is born with
the sunnier disposition,
so in a sense, climbing
Mount Happiness,
he's starting off ahead.
But if he then with the 50%
that's left up for grabs,
if he then adopts mindsets
and takes decisions
throughout his life
that don't optimize
happiness, it's very likely...
Is Luke the second one?
- Yep.
- Luke.
It's very well possible
that Luke can, you know,
overshoot him in happiness.
So I say that right off the bat.
It's obviously clear that some
of us wake up in the morning
with a completely
different daily disposition
than someone who's
more sullen and so on.
But again, that's good news.
50% is up for you to change,
and so it's exactly
what you're saying, yes.
- It's funny because
even watching them,
it took Luke a little bit
longer to start crawling,
and then the second
he started crawling,
I noticed he started
smiling more.
And it was almost as
if he wasn't that happy
'cause he was kind of stuck,
and then once he started moving,
then he allowed a little
happiness to get in there.
But let's talk about,
since we've mentioned
Jordan a couple times,
one of the things that
he talks a lot about
that I think has
helped a lot of people
is that your goal
shouldn't be happiness.
Your goal should be purpose.
First off, I sense
you agree with that,
but can you explain how
do you meld those things
and what do you see as the
difference of those things?
- Yeah, so in the last chapter
of my forthcoming
happiness book,
I have a quote by Viktor Frankl,
where he basically
says, you know,
"Don't pursue directly success.
It is something that
comes as a consequence."
And I use that because I argue
that I completely analogize
that to happiness,
and hence, I agree with Jordan.
Happiness should be
something that results
from you having adopted
the right mindsets,
the right decisions,
and so I think you mentioned
purpose and meaning.
So in one of the chapters
where I talk about
the two decisions
that are most likely to impart
either great amount of misery
or great amount of
happiness to you,
I say that the choice of
spouse that you choose
and the choice of
profession that you choose
are the ones that
are going to do that,
either make you more
miserable or happier.
And to Jordan's
point about purpose,
I wake up every day, you
know, with sort of a gleeful,
I'm rubbing my hands
together in anticipation
because my job brings me
great purpose and meaning.
Today, I'm gonna
talk with Dave Rubin.
Later, I'm gonna meet
a graduate student.
Then, I'm gonna speak
to a college in Florida.
Then, I'm gonna put
up a Saad Truth.
I'm constantly in creative mode,
so that's actually something
I talk about in the book,
that the surest way to
find purpose and meaning,
irrespective of which
profession you follow,
is to instantiate
your creative impulse.
Now, that's a very
broad statement,
because I could be a
chef and be creative.
I could be an architect,
I could be a standup comic
creating new material.
I could be a podcaster.
I could be an author
and a professor.
But all other things equal,
if you immerse yourself
in the creative impulse,
you're more likely to
find purpose and meaning.
Very few insurance adjusters
probably wake up and say,
"Thank God I'm an
insurance adjuster.
I find such purpose and
meaning doing that."
- So what do you
do for that person?
So for the person that's
an insurance adjuster
that's watching this right now,
that it's a mundane
activity, let's say.
They might have
the great spouse,
they might be making
a decent living,
but the day-to-day thing,
and I'm sure there are
some insurance adjusters
who absolutely freaking love it.
But whatever that job is,
whatever we're
talking about there,
what do you say to that person?
- Yeah, fantastic.
So there, I would say-
- Who's pulling
the levers all day.
- That's right.
So in a sense, it relates to
some of the other prescriptions
that I have in the book.
So I argue, for example,
I have a whole chapter titled
"Life as a Playground," right?
Meaning that immerse
yourself in endless play,
even when pursuing
very serious things.
So science, the
pursuit of science,
is the ultimate form of
intellectual play, right?
Because when you're
putting together,
I'm gonna come to the
insurance adjuster in a second,
when you're putting together a
puzzle, a 1,000 piece puzzle,
you're trying to make
all these pieces fit.
Well, that's what
science is, right?
There's a bunch of
variables out there,
and I'm trying to find which
one causes which other one,
which one correlates
to the other,
or is unrelated to the other.
So it's a form of
orgiastic cerebral play.
So to the insurance adjuster,
I say that perhaps your job
doesn't allow you that
creative play pursuit,
but then at night, when
you finish your job,
rather than watching television
for the next five hours,
maybe sign up for
that ceramics class
that you had always
wanted to take.
In other words,
there is still a way
for me to pursue my
creative impulse,
to immerse myself in play,
even though my profession
doesn't afford me
those opportunities.
- What would you say to the
person that's struggling?
And I think this is probably
mostly for the generation
or the several generations
now behind the two of us
who are struggling
between the balance
between pleasure and happiness?
Meaning they've grown up
where you can watch
porn all day long,
you can play video
games all day long,
you can indulge
in whatever it is
that you like to do all day
long, basically at your phone,
as opposed to getting
to the purpose
that'll bring you the happiness.
And I think a huge
amount of people
are struggling
with that balance.
- So if I were to answer that
using an endocrinological
framework,
I would say in a sense,
your question can be reframed
as the difference between
dopamine and serotonin, right?
The dopamine hits caters
to my pleasure center.
So the porn or the juicy
burger is a one-time hit.
But that's not
existential bliss, right?
That's not, right?
But when I sit down and I say,
"I am genuinely a happy person,
I've got a great family,
I love my children,
I've got great friends,
I can text Dave Rubin in a
second and he's gonna respond,"
you know, "I read
books all day,"
I am existentially happy.
So I think it's
really the difference
between short-term
hits of dopamine
and long-term
serotonin contentment,
which by the way, is something
that we can also relate
when you're choosing
your partner, right?
Many people will confuse, you
know, lust and the hormones,
the neuroanatomy of lust.
That's gonna fade.
I don't care whether
you're married
to a Greek god, Adonis,
or Beyonce, you know,
there's the old expression,
"Show me a gorgeous woman
and I'll show you a guy who's
tired of having sex with her."
Well, that also
speaks to the reality
that there is a huge
tedium that sets in
if all you are pursuing
is short-term pleasure.
But on the other hand,
for me to be able to go
for a walk with my wife
and, you know, have fun
and joke around and so on,
that's contentment.
So that's, I think, the
difference between the two.
- Do you think a lot of people
don't know what they
want in a spouse,
partly for what you're saying?
That they're just looking
for either the sexiest
person or whatever,
that they just have no
idea what their actual,
what the lanes are,
what the barriers are?
So for example, did
you see the story
just in the last week
or so about Jonah Hill
sending these texts
to his girlfriend?
Did you happen to
see this story?
- I did.
- So he sent out
what I thought were fairly well
said, controlled statements
about what his expectations
in a relationship were.
Don't party with
your girlfriends,
you know, don't send
out naked pictures.
Like, some basic stuff.
And then he said,
"Hey, if this doesn't work for
you, I'm not the right guy."
Now, of course, everyone
calls him a misogynist,
and then, you know, all the
press is going after him.
But I thought, how impressive.
There's someone actually
saying what they want
and not apologizing for it.
- So two things I'll say.
So you probably know
the Delphic maxim,
which is know thyself.
So that speaks to
your point, right?
Because he knows
what's going to be
his trajectory of happiness,
and he's saying, "This
is what I expect."
And that could only
happen if I know myself.
But if I'm going to put
the more general point
in a scientific framework,
when it comes to the
evolutionary mechanisms
of human mating,
there are two competing,
if you like, maxims.
There is the birds of a
feather flock together,
and there is the
opposites attract.
Well, it may interest
your audience
to know that the
overwhelming consensus
in the scientific literature
for long-term
happiness of a union
is birds of a feather
flock together.
- Oh, interesting.
I would've said it
the other way, wow.
- No, I'll tell you
where you might be right.
If you said the excitement of
a short-term dalliance, right?
Let's go behind the shed
and let's have some,
you know, dopamine hits,
metaphorically speaking.
Then if I am someone
who is restrained,
who's sexually shy,
who's introverted,
and you're the opposite, you
bring me out of my shell,
those things, those
opposites might attract
and i might actually come
away a lot more enriched
by the fact that
we're different.
But for long-term union,
if we share values,
if we share life goals, if
we share belief systems,
it's astoundingly more
likely that we'll be happy.
So what Jonah Hill was doing
was being a perfect
Darwinian being
and recognizing that he wants
someone who shares his values.
There's nothing wrong with that.
- Right, I wonder if in
some ways there's sort of
like a big picture/little
picture version of that,
because I always find,
like if I was to look at
me and David, for example,
we really agree on all
the big picture stuff
of what we've wanted out of
life and built things together.
And that's why, you
know, thankfully,
knock on wood, it's worked
and it's growing and all that,
but we're very different,
we're opposites when it
comes to attention to detail,
organization, all
of those things.
So I guess there's probably
a couple different layers
of all of those things.
- Exactly.
That's why when I was referring
to birds of a feather
flock together,
I specifically said
what those criteria are
that we should match on.
We're not trying to
match on our eye color.
We're not trying to match on
the morphology of our faces.
It's life goals, it's life
mindsets, it's belief systems.
That's what we're talking about,
birds of feather flock together.
Incidentally on
physicality, by the way,
there is one trait that we
also have assortative mating,
and that's on height.
So that if you look at
naturally occurring couples,
I'm talking now
heterosexual couples,
but we could easily extend
it to same-sex couples,
there was a study that was
done with 720 actual couples,
one of which, 1 out of 720,
did it violate the
assortative cue
of male should be
taller than female.
So that's a very important cue.
The only-
(Dave laughing)
- Well, this doesn't bode
well for, say, Ben Shapiro.
- Oh, his wife is taller?
- I'm not sure
exactly, but, you know,
I was just trying
to think of somebody
that's not known as very tall.
- Well, listen.
I'm not exactly breaking
the seven foot mark,
but I'm taller than my wife.
That's the most important thing.
So in other words, it's
not so much that men
have to be taller, you
know, than six feet.
I mean, yeah, that's nice.
But it's that you certainly
don't want to be with someone
who is taller than you.
And that's why if you're
a tall, educated woman,
your chances of
finding a right man
are really
precipitously decreased,
because if you're a 6'2" woman,
you are very unlikely
to want a shorter guy,
while there are very fewer men
who are 6'3" and more.
Now, if you're very
educated as a woman,
you almost never want someone
who is of lesser
educational status,
so now you have to
find a 6'4" PhD.
Good luck with that.
- What do you make of how people
now go about
finding that spouse,
where everybody's
flipping on apps
and doing all that stuff
where we've sort of
atomized all of the traits
that you might actually
have to, in the old days,
go out with somebody
and figure out?
Now by the time you sit down
with them at that restaurant,
you know what movies they like,
you know what music they like,
you found out all
of these quirks.
So we've compartmentalized
all of these things
that are about the
exploration, right?
- Right, yeah, and actually,
I've published several
academic studies
looking at sex differences
in information search
within the mating domain, right?
And what I have found, and
even in an online medium,
using actual, you
know, computer software
to track how many pieces
of information you look at.
So here's an interesting
piece of information.
When it comes to
rejection data...
What do I mean by
rejection data?
I mean how much information
do men and women need to look
at before they've seen enough
to reject potential suitors.
Well, women require a lot
less evidence to reject mates.
On the other hand, when
it comes to choosing data,
meaning when have I looked
at enough information
to now be satisfied that I'm
ready to choose whomever,
then women search
for more information.
Now, that makes perfect
evolutionary sense
because there's something
called the parental
investment theory,
which basically argues that
if you wanna understand
which of the two
sexes in a species
is going to be more
sexually choosy,
you have to look at
which of the two sexes
has the greater amount
of minimal parental
obligatory investment.
And for most species,
it is females who
have the greater
minimal parental investment.
Therefore, it looms
much larger for them
to make an erroneous
mate search.
That's why they have
to be more judicious
in their mate searches.
So there's a great song, by
the way, from the seventies,
you might know it, called,
"Why Do the Girls Get All
Prettier at Closing Time,"
or something.
Do you know that song?
- I'm not totally sure.
We'll see if we can
grab a little sample.
- Actually, it was
what led to a study.
I think it was a
1975 country song.
Basically what it was arguing,
if I couch it in
evolutionary language,
that, you know, men, when they
go to the bar at 10 at night,
they only want to have
sex with the supermodel.
At 12 o'clock, she
could be a 7 out of 10.
At three o'clock in the morning,
as long as she doesn't
have a tail and horns,
and she still has a
pulse, we're good to go.
Meaning that men relax their
threshold of acceptability
as the night of loneliness
looms in the background.
But you don't see that the
other way around, right?
There is no song that's
been written called,
"Don't the Guys Get More
Handsome Near Closing Time"
because the though of making
a wrong choice loom as large,
whether it's at 10
in the afternoon
or three in the
morning for women.
And so I discuss all of
these things, actually,
in the happiness book when
it comes to mate search.
- Are you surprised how
many people are not happy?
I mean, you know, we've
been blessed to travel
in some pretty great circles,
and, you know, I
know plenty of people
that I think are at
least roughly happy
or trying to do
something decent,
but I know a decent
amount of miserable people
that have an awful lot in
terms of what you would think
are the pieces that
make you happy.
- Oh, you are absolutely right.
I mean, we see it
on Twitter, right?
I mean, you know, I was away
for 16 days in Portugal,
and so I only posted,
you know, beach photos.
I didn't weigh in on anything.
So I was still posting things,
but never checking anything.
And I didn't check what my
blood pressure was pre and post,
but I'm almost certain
there was a huge improvement
because I wasn't exposed
to the endless misery
of people, right?
And you know me well, Dave.
Even when I'm going
after someone,
even when I am, you
know, insulting them
in some spicy way,
I always do it, I hope so,
you know, with a
playful mindset.
So it does actually amaze me
that people can be so miserable.
Now, I wonder, and
here I'm speculating,
but I think there is value
in what I'm saying here,
I wonder if the fact that
I had my childhood history,
I mean, you know it,
but maybe some of
your listeners, right?
I mean, I'm a product of
the Lebanese Civil War.
So not withstanding that I
have a sunny disposition,
the fact that I've seen
some of the truly
horrible things of life,
maybe that even adds to
my ability to be happy.
Because every time
I find a reason
to be pissed off at something,
I can easily insert that
voice in my head that says,
"You could have not gotten
out of Lebanon in 1975,
so why don't you
stop your whining,"
this is my internal voice,
"and just go out there
and appreciate life?"
So I think in some
interesting way,
the fact that I've had to face
these anti-fragile
stressors in my childhood
allows me to be that much
happier in my day-to-day.
And maybe those Twitter
miserable people,
they need to go to Raqqa, Syria
and see how people live there,
and then maybe they won't
be such miserable cretins.
- What advice would
you give for people
on the social media
front in that regard?
You know, I do my
August off the grid,
which this will be my
seventh year of doing it.
I think it actually
is one of the things
that has kept me happy and sane
and clear-minded
throughout all of this.
And I didn't lose my
mind during COVID,
and I didn't lose my mind
during Trump or any of those.
Well, I guess that's for
other people to judge,
but ballpark, I think I
kind of made it out okay.
But that social media,
which of course the
word social's in there,
we're social creatures.
It's designed to make us social,
but it actually seemingly
made us more antisocial,
more neurotic and
fearful of strangers,
and all sorts of stuff.
- Well, maybe I could answer
this by drawing an analogy.
You know, we are a
storytelling animal,
so we often learn best
not by having sort of
academic abstract ideas,
but by contextualizing
it with a story.
So to those social media,
you know, sullen folks,
listen to these two stories.
So in the last chapter of "The
Saad Truth about Happiness,"
I discuss two powerful stories
that capture the mindset
that is the antithesis of
those people on social media.
So, two stories.
Number one, arguably the
most incredible conversation
I've had on my show,
and that's saying a lot
because just like you,
I've been fortunate
enough to speak
to all sorts of
incredible people,
is a gentleman by the
name of David McCallum,
whom you probably
don't know who that is.
David McCallum is someone
who spent 29 years in prison
for a murder that he was
eventually exonerated.
I think he went into
prison at 17 years old,
and he came out well
into his forties.
And as we were
chatting on the show,
I looked at him, and you
can go watch our chat,
it's really quite powerful.
I said to him, "You
know, I'm amazed, David.
I mean, you must be a
reincarnation of Buddha
because I'm amazed that you're
not filled with vengefulness,
with vindictiveness, with anger.
You're a much better
man than I am,
because if I had been
in your position,
and if 30, 29 years had
been stolen from me,
I would wanna burn
the world down."
And then his answer,
so to speak to those
social media people
who, you know, go crazy
about every little thing,
he said, "You know,
I have a sister
who's been bedridden
with cerebral palsy
for much of her life,
and yet she still
finds time to smile
and be grateful
for what she has.
And so viewed from
that perspective,
I don't really have
much to be angry about."
I mean, that's an
incredibly powerful story.
Second guy that
I'll tell you about
is a gentleman whom I met.
So when I was a professor
at University of
California Irvine,
I was sitting at a
cafe in Newport Beach,
you know, working on
some paper, whatever,
and I had a whole bunch of
books all over the table.
And this gentleman
comes up, says,
"Oh, lovely collection
of books you've got here.
Do you mind if I sit
with you and chat?"
It turned out that he was
a PhD student at UC Irvine,
completing his
doctoral dissertation
on studying homelessness.
He had immersed himself
within the homeless community
to learn more about
sort of their ecosystem,
and eventually he
became homeless himself.
And he was a
wealthy Persian guy.
So he came from money,
he had a lot of money,
and then several years later
he became a homeless guy.
Well, I tracked him down.
There's an article that I
cite in the book from 2011,
so this is about 10
years after we had met,
where someone is asking him,
"Are you happy? Are you sad?
How do you deal with what's
happened in your life?"
And his answer, again,
is a good answer
to those social
media sullen people.
He said, "I've got
access to a gym
where I can keep
my body healthy.
I've got access to the
Newport Beach Library
so I can keep my mind nourished.
I've got nothing to be
angry or sad about."
Those are powerful stories.
So to those people who go
crazy about Trump and so on,
there is such a bigger
world out there.
There is such misery out there.
Be grateful.
- Can I tell you something
that just popped in my head
as you were telling that story?
I have not thought about
this for probably 20 years,
I'm not kidding you,
but when I was in my mid
twenties and I was messed up
because I was closeted
and, you know,
struggling stand up, and I had
no money, all of that stuff,
I used to stand on the
corners in Times Square,
handing out tickets to get
people to come to the shows.
That's how you get stage time.
And there was this
homeless guy out there,
his name was Charlie,
'cause he was always panhandling
while we were
handing out tickets.
And I always used to think,
"It's kind of funny,
I'm basically doing the same
thing as a homeless guy."
But Charlie had the
biggest freaking smile
on his face all the time,
which I very
specifically remember
'cause his teeth were horribly
mangled and everything else,
but always was smiling,
joking around with everybody.
He had a very funny sign about
how he was gonna, he said,
"I'm not gonna bullshit you,
I'm just gonna spend the
money on booze and weed,
but come on, why not?"
And he was just funny.
And I remember thinking,
"That homeless man
is happier than me."
And that is one of the things
that started turning me around
because I thought, "I have
every opportunity in this world.
This guy has none."
And I truly have not
thought about that
for 20 some odd years,
and that just sparked out of me.
- I'm glad that
it triggered that.
Look, right now I've
started my big tour,
this media thing for the book,
and so, you know, this weekend
I was looking at my entire
schedule, I was like,
"Oh my God, I've gotta travel
here, I gotta do this."
And then I stopped.
I said, "Am I really
whining about the fact
that I've got all
these opportunities
and I have a book coming out?
Eff off, Gad Saad."
And so I think if you've got
that internal voice
of authenticity,
you're always able
to snap yourself
back into the right mindset.
- Yeah.
What are some of the other
tricks that people can use
if they're really in a funk?
You know, when somebody,
when you're in those
moments in life
that you're just tripped up,
family problems, money problems,
you're doing the job
you don't wanna do,
like the whole thing
seems like it's off.
Do you have some tricks
that can kind of just
get someone going?
'Cause it seems
like that first step
is often the biggest hurdle.
- Oh, sure.
So I have a whole chapter,
so it speaks partially to
the question you're asking,
I have a whole chapter
on sort of how can you
minimize regret in life?
Because regret in a sense
is that existential,
you know, voice that
keeps coming in your head
that makes you think, what
if, what if I had done this,
what if I had done that, right?
And so many of us think that
opportunities for happiness
have passed us by.
We're too old to be, let's say,
I know that you love the NBA.
Well, that is true.
That is objectively true.
It would be silly for you or I
to think about being NBA stars,
although you have seen some
of my three point shots,
so maybe I can still make it.
Plus, Muggsy Bogues was 5'2".
- We have had some good
back and forth.
- That's right. That's right.
But no, but seriously,
there are many cases
where that sense of, "I
can't get out of this funk,"
is sort of a deterministic doom.
Whereas in reality,
you've placed this
restriction in your...
So let me give you,
again, two examples.
Example one, this
is from in the book.
There's a gentleman who
left pre-Nazi Germany,
he was a Jewish guy,
left and came to Canada,
had always wanted to study
and, you know, get a
university education,
but life circumstances
didn't allow him to.
He comes to Canada as a
young kid, goes to work,
has a successful career,
retires in his sixties.
Now, he's in his sixties, right?
I mean, average
undergrad is 20, 19.
He says, "You know what?
I'm of good mind, I have time.
Why don't I sign up?"
He actually went to the
university that I work at.
And he said, "Why
don't I sign up
and take some
undergraduate courses?"
Lo and behold, a
few years later, he
finishes his undergrad.
Then he says, "Hey,
I'm still young.
I'm now in my seventies.
Why don't I pursue
my master's degree?"
Finishes it.
And then in his
eighties, starts his PhD.
And I remember,
this was in 1996,
it was very early in
my academic career,
the university
newspaper had the title,
something like, "Finally
a Doctor at 91."
And so he finishes his PhD and
within a year he passes away.
So he could have easily said,
"You know, I missed my
opportunity to study."
Well, no, you had an opportunity
to do it and you did it.
Second example, I just had
this guy last year on my show.
This is a physician
who got, I think,
his medical degree at
University of Vienna in 1955.
Then while he was training
to be a hematologist
as a specialist, picked
up a PhD in 1967.
You weren't born yet.
I was two years old, two
and a half years old.
But he had always wanted
to be a physicist.
His real love was physics.
But his family had
told him, Jewish guy,
"You have to do
something practical,
become a physician,
blah, blah, blah."
And he did it.
At the age of 89,
he completed a
second PhD in physics
at Brown University.
So why am I telling you,
again, these stories?
Because oftentimes
we are in a funk
because we place
these arbitrary,
illusionary barriers
in our minds.
Yes, we can't be
future NBA stars.
We're too old for that.
We can't be ballerinas,
we're not gonna be
maestro violinists.
But for many other things
that would make us happy,
it's only our inner voice
that's stopping us from doing,
so get off the
couch and go do it.
- Can you be too
happy, do you think?
I mean, we all know the person
that just kinda
lives in the clouds
that may be smiling
all the time,
but really isn't on the ball
or basically isn't
on planet earth.
- Lex Fridman.
Sorry, I had something
stuck in my...
Well, he's not really, not that
I wanted to talk about him,
but I argue he engages
in faux happiness, right?
He's always, "I love you,
you love me, let's hug."
I think that-
- What was his tweet
a couple weeks ago
that everybody went crazy on,
I think you really
nailed him on?
Wasn't there something
not too long ago?
- "I don't care
whether you call
yourself male or female,
I care about what
your character is,"
or something like that.
And that pissed me off.
Now again, people think
when I go after someone,
I'm trying to be mean.
I'm not, and that's because
there's a part of me
that's a dogged
defender of truth.
And actually, I talk
about this in the book,
that existential authenticity
is a sure pathway
to happiness, right?
I present myself to the world
as though I'm 18 feet tall
because I'm always authentic.
I really know my qualities,
I know my faults.
I don't modulate anything.
And so there are no
fissures in my personhood,
and that's why I then can feel
comfortable in any setting
because I don't
have to retain lies.
For better or worse, here I am.
And what I was pissed
with Lex is, you know,
I didn't know who
Lex was, frankly,
but then people said, "Oh,
you should go on his show."
That's how I started
getting to know him.
And then I would see
all this inane bullshit
that he would consistently
post, and it just pissed me off.
So in his case, I don't know
if he's being real or not.
He has gone into
the extra happiness
because not everything in life
is about hugging and
happiness, right?
I mean, that's a false narrative
and that's why I
tried to go after him.
And now to his lack of
credit, he always says,
"Oh, I always am willing
to learn from anyone
and speak to anyone."
First thing he does
is he blocks me.
What a schmuck.
(Dave laughs)
- So you can be happy and still
think someone's a schmuck.
That's good, that
should definitely-
- Exactly right.
And by the way, to that
point, people often say to me,
when they meet me,
"Oh, you seem so much
nicer and friendlier
than on social media."
No, because this is called
situational specificity, right?
If you attack me in an alley,
I might be violent 'cause
you're trying to mug me.
That's not because I'm
dispositionally violent,
it's because I act differently
when I'm tucking
my children to bed
and when I'm being
mugged in an alley.
So when I am being mugged
by assholes on social media,
I act in a spicier manner
not because I'm not
happy or I'm mean,
it's because
different strategies
require different approaches.
I mean, or different context.
- So you're a little happier
when you're basically
putting your kids to sleep
than you are when
you're being mugged.
I just wanna make sure
I got that one clear.
- That is a correct
statement, indeed.
- What about the
things that people
at least get the
temporary happiness on,
whether it might be the booze
or the extra indulgence in food
or whatever they might be
smoking or the other stuff?
- Completely fleeting.
So I talk about in the book,
as someone who studies
consumer psychology, right,
so I wanted to link it to
some of my own interests.
So there's been
now several studies
that have looked at
whether spending money
on material possessions,
so that speaks to kind
of your point, right?
Should I get the next Prada bag
or the really cool
Gucci or the Maserati?
What brings you greater
long-term happiness,
the spending money on
material possessions
or on experiences?
And overwhelmingly,
repeatedly, the research shows
that for long-term
enduring happiness,
living a life of
rich experiences
is going to bring you a
lot more bang for the buck
than if you spend
it on a Ferrari.
And I know this from
personal experience
because one of my brothers
who until recently lived
in Southern California
and was very, very wealthy
during the dotcom era,
he had not one, not
two, but three Ferraris.
He had an Aston Martin Lagonda.
He was a collector of
conspicuous consumption goods.
I hate to say it, and I
don't say this with any glee,
I don't think today
he's happy, right?
Whereas I never drove a Ferrari,
I never had access to a Ferrari,
but later today, my
children are going to come
and are gonna say, "Oh, how
was your chat with Dave Rubin?"
That moment right there
probably makes me wealthier
than all of his
Ferraris put together.
- When you get to
the happiness part,
so the place that you're
basically at in your life
at this moment,
do you have to keep
doing work to sustain it?
Or at that point, if you
feel like you got it right,
you can just kind
of ride it out?
I mean, do you feel like there
are things on the horizon
beyond you have to
keep doing your work,
keep maintaining that
good relationship?
Is there anything
else you gotta do
to really keep pushing forward?
- Well, I think, yeah,
amazing question.
I think you have to keep
implementing those strategies
that ensure that you are
going to remain happy.
If I were to analogize it,
if I now get off my very
obsessive weight concerns,
it won't take me long
before we get two
times Gad again, right?
In other words, I mean,
literally, I probably-
- You know, I have to
say, I have to say, Gad,
two times weight
Gad, pretty happy.
He was pretty happy
as far as I can tell.
- I was pretty happy.
Although my blood
pressure was not as happy,
although my physician
was not as happy with me.
So again, I think
from the perspective
of extending my happiness
as far as I can go,
literally in terms
of life expectancy
and contrary to what
Professor Dr. Lizzo tells us,
you know what I'm talking about,
right, Lizzo's got-
- Yes, I got it, Lizzo.
They're fortifying the stage.
- They're fortifying the stage.
And she argues that, you know,
"Stop talking
about this nonsense
about health being
related to your weight.
That's just a construct."
My life expectancy,
knock on wood,
is hopefully going to, you know,
drastically increase
by virtue of, you know,
my having now be at
the right weight.
But I have to always
be careful, right?
And so to your point
about happiness,
I don't think you can get to
Mount Happiness, to the summit,
and say, "I've done it all,
now let me take crystal meth
and I will continue
to be happy."
You still have to work
on your relationships,
you still have to be playful,
you still have to
nourish your mind.
All those things are
perpetual pursuits.
- Gad, watch very closely
the screen right now,
because I'm gonna wink at you
as I ask you this question.
Can you mindfully meditate
yourself into happiness?
(Gad laughs)
- It's incredible.
- Some of the audience
will know what I just
asked and some will not.
It's okay.
- Yes, yes, yes.
As a matter of fact, so
in one of the chapters,
I'm gonna come to your mindful
meditation in a second,
in one of the
chapters I talk about
the fundamentally most
powerful law in nature,
which is what I call
the inverted U curve.
Inverted U, which the ancient
Greeks already knew about,
is too little of
something is not good,
too much of something
is not good,
and the sweet spot is
somewhere in the middle,
which Aristotle referred
to as the golden mean,
which Buddha referred
to as the middle way.
Maimonides referred to it.
And so in that chapter,
I demonstrate that across a
bewildering number of contexts,
that inverted U applies,
including to mindful meditation,
meaning that if you
never are mindful
in terms of meditating or taking
a deep breath or something,
it's not good,
but doing it too
much, it's not good.
And actually that
speaks to a tweet
that I think Elon Musk.
- I think Elon Musk sent-
- Had sent to that person
in question saying,
"So and so, there is such a
thing as too much meditation."
So that exactly
speaks to your point.
Always find the middle
way, the sweet spot.
You'll be happier.
- Gad, I have to say one
of my great joys in life
is that I think I found the
spouse I was supposed to find.
We'll put that one aside.
But the other one,
that I'm doing the work that
I'm supposed to be doing,
and that it has allowed
me to have friendships
like I have with you,
'cause we've done this now,
it seems like a long time,
but it ain't that long.
But we both somehow
still manage to do this
with a smile on our face
and to traverse some new ground.
And that's why it's a pleasure
always talking to
you, my friend.
- You're a delight.
Big e-hug, and I hope to
see you in Florida soon.
- What else can I offer you?
Freedom, low taxes,
the weather's great.
You'll keep the tan.
I mean, what am I doing here?
You're okay with sweating.
- Give me some-
- Tenure.
- Way to replace my
tenured professorship.
- "Give Me Tenure
or Give Me Death."
That could be your next book.
(Gad laughs)
The book is "Happiness:
8 Secrets for Leading
the Good Life."
Gad Saad is leading a good life.
Good to see you, my friend.
- Thank you, Dave.
So good to talk to you. Cheers.
- If you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful
conversations about academia,
check out our academia playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlist all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.